welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who
always spots the devil in the details
and this video we're breaking down the
third episode of one division
as emil blonsky once said this is a
whole new level of weird
and we ended last week with wanda
revealing that she was pregnant
now though in this episode she doesn't
get an ultron sound hey having that
clearly the children are a big focus of
what's going on
in the first entry we watched his
visions boss mr hart
started hammering his hand whilst asking
why the pair didn't have any kids
in the second episode there was a big
committee built towards doing things for
them
and you'd have to be blind not to have
the vision that it's clearly the
children that they're after
terrible puns anyway because wonder is
able to alter reality
i believe that the true villains of the
show had been trying their best to
subliminally plant the idea in her head
that she needed to have kids we'll talk
about how this ties into the overall
plot and where things could be going
later on
but after multiple watches of the first
two episodes i think it becomes clear
that wonder likely
wandered into this town was manipulated
by agnes and then transformed the
landscape into the sitcom show that we
see
my editor christian from beyond epic
went through the old trailers
and actually discovered a moment in
which it looks like monica
is about to put her hand into a bubble
and we can see that from the outside
it looks like the town is fine this
makes me believe that whoever is getting
wandered to do this
doesn't want the rest of the world to
know and thus is making things seem like
normal from the outside
this is clearly a metaphor that carries
over to the show itself
as everything looks bright and bubbly in
this sitcom world but we know
deep beneath the surface that something
else is going on
agnes clearly wants the kids and if the
theories about mephisto
aka the devil being behind it all are
true then he's likely engineered
everything to get them
in the first two entries there was of
course a discussion between agnes and
dottie in which they said the devil's in
the detail
and that's not the only place he is yeah
i've done that joke already now vision
also had a stick of big red gum
which could also be a no to satan
himself
in the loki trailer there's also a
moment in which we can see the devil in
a stained glass window
somehow all the clues are pointing
towards him being behind it all
now this actually ties back to the
comics themselves as when wanda fell
pregnant it was revealed that her babies
were actually being used to carry the
souls of demons
though this is all just a fan theory for
now looking at not only the source
material but also the clues and hints
it does seem to line up let's be honest
although we don't know whether hydra
will be playing a part in this or not
the logo did feature an episode too and
i just want to shout out at
hooligansbarry on twitter
for pointing out that the tentacles look
like 666.
now that might be a reach but if we take
the symbolism of the logo and look at
the sword one
it looks like a sword that's piercing
through a bubble in order to burst it
the episode itself ends with a big
reveal that we'll talk about later on in
the video
but it's very clear that there are
indeed people trying to investigate the
truth of the matter
i think this highlights that their
mission is to try and save wonder from
the bubble reality that she's trapped in
and that mephisto and agnes or rather
agatha
will try and do what they can to stop
this from happening hexagons appear
throughout the series especially in the
credits
and they could highlight that the pair
have been hexed it's also possible that
they could be hinting towards wanda's
own hex powers from the comics
as in the original work she was able to
craft hex spears
bolts and more so yeah just tying the
two things together
now episode three itself pulls heavily
from the 70s sitcom the brady bunch
in both its style and decor if you look
back at old photographs of the brady
bunch house
you'll see that they've clearly modeled
not only the timberwork from it
but also the way that the stairs align
too the similarities actually go beyond
this as well
and if you're a fan of sitcoms in
general then you may have heard of
something called cousin oliver syndrome
in the brady bunch when writing started
to slip the creative team behind the
show actually brought in an extended
member of the family called cousin
oliver
completely out of nowhere he just they
just made him up i'm not even lying he
just popped up on set one day you know
cousin oliver syndrome
basically refers to a show bringing in a
cute character in order to try and boost
viewership and if we take that idea and
apply it to one division
then the pregnancy which popped out of
nowhere could be making jabs at the
motif
however as we've discussed it's clearly
part of the plot
and it's a smart way to not only pay
homage to the stereotypes
but use them to advance the story now
the brady bunch inspired opening and
theme itself
actually show a bit of a mistake in the
makeup department
when vision is on the swing if you look
closely at his shirt
you'll see that they didn't apply the
makeup to his arm and his skin can be
seen beneath this sleeve
no tinnoti i also kind of get the
feeling that vision himself subliminally
knew that he was getting twins
as he builds two swings and a seesaw
both of which
can only be used by two children but i
grew up a single child i'm just kidding
i've got a sister now the pregnancy book
he also reads
looks very ominous and it's almost
occult in several ways due to the
shadowy figure standing against the
blood red background
the name is difficult to make out but it
appears to say agnes
however let me know if i'm wrong as it
goes by so quickly
the words in color also appear and this
was actually seen as a big upgrade at
the time in tv
the show itself has gone from black and
white to being coloured
so this is also a nice little meta joke
over how the series has transformed
throughout the episode we can also see
that the camera techniques used have
been massively upgraded over the last
entry
in the prior episodes most shots were
static whereas here they're far more
dynamic
mimicking techniques that were adopted
at the time this shows how much
attention marvel were paying to what was
going on in television during the 70s
and it's definitely something that they
should be applauded for it's not too
long before we see a doctor
listening out for the heartbeat of the
little baby he's unable to detect twins
which are later revealed
and this to me signifies that wonder may
have manifested them
after the pair were torn between the
names we learn that the doctor himself
is planning a trip to bermuda baby
and i'm sure you're well aware of the
bermuda triangle the area itself
also has the nickname the devil's
triangle which could further tie back to
mephisto
it's a loosely defined location in which
a number of aircrafts and ships are said
to have disappeared under mysterious
circumstances
and this of course is similar to how we
know that the town has disappeared along
with its occupants
the doctor himself could have come in
and vanished similar to how monica has
and therefore the idea of bermuda is in
the back of his mind
influencing his idea of escape now
outside i love how we see ralph cutting
a brick wall
and you may notice behind him that the
background is painted on
rather than being an actual field he
seems a bit lost in the illusion
and it is possible that this wall used
to be a fence which is why confusion
comes over it
however it is possible that he may be
another character
which we'll talk about in just a bit now
we see vision demonstrate his super
speed and catching a papaya
and this actually ties into the children
that the pair had in the comics
together they created wiccan and speed
two mutants blessed with incredible
gifts
the latter of which was super speed this
seems like the direction that they are
going to
as they go back and forth over the names
of children
and con settle on either tommy or billy
now interestingly enough
billy and tommy were also the names
given to the two that were possessed by
demon souls in the comics
and after they were vanquished they
later reincarnated as wicked in speed
i think anyway yeah these old comics are
all over the place
and like wonder herself marvel seem to
enjoy pressing the reset button
and removing things from the timeline so
excuse me if i'm wrong but i don't think
i am yet so shut the hell up
now i think that this show will probably
skip the evil demon souls versions
and just go straight into the wicked and
speed ones and then combine the
backstory with mephisto and agnes
likely wanting to possess them wanda has
a stork painted on the wall
and this later comes to life perhaps
signifying how she was able to bring
vision back from the dead
if that is the case then this isn't the
version
that we've come to know and love and it
is possible that when this reality falls
apart eventually that he goes with it
i think it would be heartbreaking to end
the show with him dying once more
and he could set up wonder as the
villain going forward similar to how she
is in house of m
well i say villain yeah she's just a bit
of a bit of a crazy mess
now now there's a cool not slugger off
now there's a cool little cut to the
neighbors
and we see a newspaper being read with
the headline two fire hydrants added on
main
similar to the last newspaper article
which was about a baby's first words
it's barely front page newsworthy and
feels disconnected from anything with
major consequences
we know that the snap and blip have
happened on the outside world
and this not appearing anywhere shows
how idyllic this reality is
there's a strange rumbling in the house
and this could actually be the agents of
sword outside trying to infiltrate the
reality
or carry out experiments on it later we
do see spotlight shining on the location
and there is a bright beam that appears
in the living room perhaps
linking the two together either way it's
clear that wonder is controlling it all
and will do anything to keep up the
illusion and once more she rewinds
time when vision starts to question
west's view and the reality that they
live
in she did this last time with the
beekeeper and carries it out here
only this time we see things purely from
vision's perspective
and the jarring cut sort of snaps you
out of questioning it
it's really quickly and smartly edited
and it's not too long before
we stop guessing about things and just
once more gets sucked back into it
now i did start to feel a lot of truman
show vibes in this entry
especially as the characters on the
whole seem to be completely unaware that
they're part of a tv show
anytime the illusion is almost broken
drastic measures are taken to reset
things
and vision suit even looks very similar
to the one that jim carrey wears in that
movie
now occur to the commercial and this
time we get some cool 70s cube effects
it's another nod to hydra but most
importantly we see the man and woman
return
still we have no idea who these are and
it is possible that they're actually
wonders parents
they're always spelled into something
that's heavily influenced her life
such as the stock missiles or hydra
itself
they don't appear anywhere else in the
show outside of this
and that could be because if one
actually came face to face with them
that it would break the reality much in
the same way that the mention of ultron
does i've also seen people say that they
could be mephisto and death
and the line find the goddess within
could indeed signify that
after the water breaks we do get that
soap commercial
so perhaps they are linked on a level
that we don't quite know yet
when vision flees to get a doctor the
stork comes to life
and we're then greeted by geraldine or
rather monica
last week she didn't know her name until
her hand actually touched wonders
and therefore it's likely that this was
implanted into her head
after wanda says geraldine in this entry
for the first time
monica says no no no it's foxy
and though this could be referencing the
coat that she's wearing
it may also mean that she's changed her
name foxy was a very popular name in the
70s
and it could be referencing foxy brown
which is a character that i think
monica's look is based upon
this week she seems very much a
caricature and it could also be a nod to
how black people were portrayed more as
stereotypes and sitcoms that featured
predominantly white casts
monica then goes on to tell the story of
how she had a meeting with her temp boss
who we discover is called mr haddick
haddock is of course a fish
and they appear patented on her pants
perhaps showing that people's
subconscious in this reality
affects the things around them the stalk
then comes out
walks around the area and wonder tries
to make it disappear with her red smoke
powers
but she's unable to red smoke is of
course a symbol of the devil
and it could also explain why this stalk
doesn't vanish
now an interesting thing about monica is
that she has a sword necklace on
further tying back to her role on the
outside we do know that she's part of
the organization
and was sent in to get here and likely
will report on the outside exactly what
happened
her necklace was also clearly brought on
by her subconsciousness too
and yeah i'm getting sick i'm getting
sick of saying that as well now the
weird thing about vision
is that he doesn't mind showing his
super speed to the doctor
i don't really know why this doesn't
cause further alarm
either way everyone seems to be
distracted completely by the pregnancy
but it is something that stands out
quite a lot in this episode
now wonder gives birth to two babies and
notes that tommy is strong
potentially hinting towards the powers
that he could have
another bambino pops out and it's only
when monica looks over them that things
really start to get weird now we did see
in the trailers for the show that it was
actually wonder that flung her
out of the reality however the scene is
completely cut
and we're just left wondering what
happened the doctor decides not to leave
and says that the reality is hard to
escape from
and questioning that vision then sees
agnes ralph discussing something
secretive
i think that wrath may actually be
mephisto as he's the one who gave the
big red gum to vision last week
agnes also says that he looks better in
the dark perhaps hinting at him
working in the shadows however he does
hint that he may
not be real and almost blabs about
what's going on
which i don't know if the devil would do
either way they clearly want monica gone
and try to make vision turn on her by
mentioning that she has no home
this of course is a homey location and
thus the negative connotation would have
an effect on vision's perception of her
now he's not a he's not a bad guy yet so
they won't change his mind
but they do get their own way and it's
not too long before she's gone
when is brought up something in monika
changes
and this is likely because as a member
of sword
she's well aware of the ins and outs of
sokovia i love how wanda sings her song
in her native tongue
and it's clear that she starts to
remember her life which begins to break
the illusion
rather than facing the reality of the
situation though wonder simply throws
moniker away
and goes back to her idyllic life
trapped in this reality
on the outside we see the true sign for
west view highlighting that
this is indeed a relocation the first
initials of w
and v of course apply to wonder and
vision and i love how they've managed to
line them up
and make everything sort of all related
in some form or another
now in the background we also hear the
song sleepy jean which could tie into
the dream theory that we had last week
i don't want to spend ages talking about
that again because you know this is
going on for long enough
but if you checked out our last video
then you'll know in the ads for one
division that the narrator said
dreaming instead of streaming therefore
we can take it that this is actually a
dream that has come into reality
i'm guessing we'll see a lot of things
from sword's perspective next time
involving their investigation into the
bubble now i have to say that
i think this week's episode is a big
step up from the first two
i can see why disney released the first
three for review
as those two on their own just felt a
bit meh to me
however you start to get a clearer
picture here what's going on
and things just start to slot into place
it makes every single ironic joke
the strange character beats him more
just make more sense to me
and therefore i'm enjoying it more i
think most people would have come back
after last week
as we trust marvel know what they're
doing and if the episodes keep getting
better and better each time as they have
then i'm looking forward to what's
around the corner i had genuine chills
in the conversation with monica
and i love that the show can switch on a
dime in a second it goes
from the absurd to very very tense and
tonally it works
excellently in my opinion now that we
have an understanding of the mechanics
of the show
and at least some context though i did
watch sitcoms like bewitched and so on
things like the brady bunch are easier
for me to relate to but yeah
let me know if you're still lost on the
show in the comments below
now for the next part of the video we're
going to be talking about one of the big
big leaks that's just come out in
regards to the show
heavy spoilers warning also i'd
massively appreciate it if you clicked
the thumbs up button
as my last breakdown actually ended up
trending at number seven on youtube
and it just shows companies that i'm
worth working with as i didn't get
access to any screeners for this show
getting to see stuff early just helps to
make the breakdowns better
so all support is of course massively
appreciated
anyway if you've been following all the
updates on the show and you will have
seen that a spanish voice actor actually
confirmed that they are dubbing evan
peters
who will be playing quicksilver what do
you mean it's it's saying stuff like
that which is exactly why disney don't
want to work with me
[ __ ] well i have actually waited over a
week to talk about this
and the story broke last saturday and
was then later confirmed by andy signal
now though we don't know how quick silva
will be brought across to the show just
yet
it does of course open the door for
others from the multiverse such as the
x-men cast and deadpool to drop in
we already know that ryan rowlands has
signed on to do multiple marvel movies
now
and wonder may open a portal when trying
to resurrect her brother
and this could bring the fox version
into the mcu timeline
it's really going to bridge the gap
between the franchises and it also means
that kevin feig he can pick and choose
from the cast to see which actors that
he wants to work with
sorry sophie turner uh my mom says i'm
only allowed
three three people in the mcu i'm just
kidding she was fine wasn't she anyway
i think that ever since days of future
past that foggy has wanted to get
quicksilver over as he's one of the
coolest characters in it
it can also usher in his father magneto
which could lend itself to wonder
and there's just so many amazing
opportunities to tie everything together
and that's obviously a big spoiler but i
did warn you but yeah so far that's one
of the only things that i've seen leaked
about the show
anyway that wraps up our episode 3
breakdown and i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you drop a
comment below if you have any other
theories
as people's input last time it
definitely helped me to collect my
thoughts for this one
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of january
in which we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k
box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the entry if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the last
two episodes which will be linked on
screen right now
we went over both from top to bottom so
it's definitely worth checking out
if you want to know more without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace